so nevada is certainly uh seeing
record-breaking covet 19 numbers as the
virus continues to spread across our
state
the pandemic also leading to a major
increase in mental health needs
the i-team's vanessa murphy has been
looking into this and she joins us now
live to explain vanessa
denise the number of nevadans struggling
emotionally right now
has skyrocketed and the number of
children receiving help for behavioral
health needs has also gone up
on a call with reporters today about
covet 19
in the state we heard from a senior
advisor with the nevada department of
health and human services
dr stephanie woodard says data is
reflecting just how much the pandemic is
taking a
toll on nevadans emotionally and
psychologically and the number of adults
struggling emotionally is three to four
times what it usually
of loss of loved ones financial
instability
job loss housing and food insecurity
social isolation concern over exposure
to covid
managing working from home and schooling
children
are all very real examples of
significant stressors
facing our fellow nevada
and there are challenges children are
facing in this november in a november
16th letter to health care providers
the department noted the pandemic is an
adverse
childhood experience there is a decrease
in reported child abuse because people
who usually report it
don't have the same access to the kids
teachers don't have the same eyes on
them
there are increases in calls to
children's mobile crisis hotlines
and an increase in youth suicides and
dhhs is reminding nevadans to
be aware be a vigilant and if you see a
problem if you suspect
neglect or refuse to report it there are
resources
available to protect children and also
mental health re
resources for children and adults we
have more information
at 8newsnow.com reporting live vanessa
murphy
8 news now